um almost a year ago this war started
and ever since ever since the iea has
been active has been present has been
there
myself I was in Ukraine already six
times
including zaprintia which is of course
part of Ukraine albeit the fact that it
is occupied territory
and we were there not just for photo
opportunities we were there working and
doing some stuff and this is what I'm
will try to explain uh to you now the
situation throughout Ukraine of course
in in military terms it's were released
and you know it it is not getting any
any better
and if anything uh there is um quite um
clear indication of a possibility of an
increase in military activity uh by the
end of the winter and perhaps early
spring which of course races our degree
of concern in terms of the consequences
that this may have on the nuclear
infrastructure of course on every
infrastructure but my remit is limited
to this to this one on it the situation
today at the plant
um is as follows the plant is not
producing energy for the Ukrainian grid
the plant is at what we call in the
nuclear jargon shutdown hold hot shut
down and cold shut down the the
temperatures depending on the regime the
Opera the the reactors are operating
it's in a very low level of operation
that you need you know nuclear reactors
are not like you know a lamp that you
see switch on switch off you have to
have a certain level of activity to
allow them to kick in and for the safety
systems
these days over the past few days what
we have seen is not direct selling on
the plant itself but rather
on the vicinity with with a repeated
rounds of bombing and our inspectors are
hearing it in the vicinity of it so
there is the situation is is pretty
pretty tense as you can of course
imagine
this is once we established our
permanent presence there this is what
led me to propose the establishment of a
nuclear safety a protection Zone around
the plant which is in in in in in plain
English is simply establishing an area
which like a bubble that should be
excluded from military action
principle being don't shoot at the plant
or very important for Ukraine don't use
the plant to place military equipment to
attack
the the other side view of that and
benefiting already from the presence of
our permanent missions there this
morning I instructed my teams to
address a comprehensive review of the
facilities in collaboration and in
cooperation with the Ukrainian
management of these facilities to a
certain whether there is in fact any
military equipment
in-store or stationed or being moved
there and of course the results of those
inspections was was negative and we are
going to be reporting about this I would
say this is an interest interesting
thing because it's the second time that
that in a in a calm way technique away
the iea has been able to debunk
accusations of illegal things and very
dangerous things taking place in these
facilities you may remember the
allegations about dirty bombs that took
place I think last September August
September when or perhaps even later
when there was an allegation that since
in three different places
one research and development
organization another conversion facility
and another place that ukrainians were
putting together dirty bombs you know
dirty bombs are not nuclear weapons and
Conventional Weapons spiked with nuclear
material for panic and other things and
it was said at that time that because of
this perhaps nuclear weapons could be
used to reply immediately we acted we
inspected and we were able to come to
the conclusion that none of that that
all nuclear material in those an
establishment was well accounted for and
there was no reason to accept the idea
that this was happening